et je vais parler de ce qu'est un mâle alpha,
car je pense qu'on peut en apprendre beaucoup sur cette espèce
proche de la nôtre et dans laquelle on trouve des mâles alpha.
Comme exemple, je vous présente Amos, un jeune mâle que je connaissais
qui était un jeune mâle alpha.
Il était très populaire,
mais il est tombé malade
et il a perdu son statut car les chimpanzés mâles
peuvent repérer la faiblesse à plus d'un kilomètre,
et ils s'en sont pris à lui.
Il a perdu son statut, il est devenu de plus en plus malade
jusqu'au point où on a dû l'isoler.
Le groupe vivait sur une île herbeuse,
et on a dû l'isoler dans une cage,
en la laissant entr'ouverte, afin que les autres chimpanzés
puissent encore aller le voir.
Ce qu'il s'est passé était très touchant.
Ils lui amenaient à manger,
et de la laine de bois,
qu'ils utilisent pour dormir et pour construire des nids,
et que les femelles lui glissaient dans le dos.
Il s'adossait lourdement contre le mur,
et, comme on ferait avec des coussins pour un patient alité,
elles lui glissaient cela dans le dos.
Je me suis dit que c'était la voie à suivre pour un mâle alpha.
Il était aimé et respecté, et tout le monde s'occupait de lui.
Ça ne se passe pas toujours comme ça
parce que certains mâles finissent mal une fois leur statut perdu.
Amos était un exemple de mâle qui était aimé en tant que chef.
Le terme de mâle alpha, si vous le cherchez sur internet,
vous trouverez tous ces livres de management sur comment en devenir un,
ce qui signifie pour eux comment battre les autres,
leur taper sur la tête en leur montrant que vous êtes le chef,
et « Ne me cherchez pas », etc.
En gros, pour eux, un mâle alpha, c'est un tyran.
Et je n'aime pas vraiment ce type de description,
car je suis partiellement à l'origine de l'expression « mâle alpha »
puisque j'ai écrit « La Politique du chimpanzé »,
qui a été recommandé par Newt Gingrich aux nouveaux membres du Congrès.
Je ne sais pas ce que ça leur a apporté, mais il leur a recommandé ce livre,
et ensuite, l'expression « mâle alpha » est devenue très populaire.
Mais je pense qu'elle est mal interprétée.
Elle est employée de manière très superficielle,
sans rapport avec ce qu'est réellement un mâle alpha.
Je suis donc là pour expliquer de quoi il s'agit.
Le terme lui-même remonte à bien plus loin.
Il vient des années 40 et 50, de la recherche sur les loups,
et sa définition est en fait très simple.
Le mâle alpha est celui au plus haut rang.
La femelle alpha est au plus haut rang.
Tout groupe de primates a un mâle alpha, une femelle alpha,
un seul, et c'est tout.
Et je vais expliquer comment ça se passe.
Premièrement, le langage corporel.
Vous voyez ici deux mâles chimpanzés de la même taille,
mais l'un d'eux marche debout, les poils hérissés,
avec une grosse pierre en main : c'est le mâle alpha.
L'autre mâle émet un grognement haleté,
il lui est soumis, et s'incline devant lui.
C'est le type de rituel qui doit être renouvelé plusieurs fois par jour
pour garder une relation stable.
Observons une vidéo prise sur le terrain.
Vous verrez une femelle émettant un grognement haleté vers un mâle alpha
et vous verrez ce qu'il se passe.
Le mâle approche,
elle grogne.
(Grognements de la femelle)
Les poils du mâle sont hérissés
et il parade.
En réalité, je filme de trop près.
Un chimpanzé est bien plus puissant que moi,
et je me suis montré imprudent en filmant cette vidéo.
Alors, vous venez de le voir
se soulever et se tenir sur deux pattes,
en étirant les bras.
C'est la parade bipède.
Les mâles de haut rang pratiquent beaucoup cette posture,
et elle est très reconnaissable, car les humains le font aussi.
(Rires)
Les humains font ça tout le temps.
Et ce que j'aime surtout avec cette image,
ce sont les deux mâles plus âgés sur les côtés.
Ça fait très chimpanzé.
Chez les chimpanzés,
il y a généralement des mâles âgés qui ont fait leur temps,
qui ne peuvent plus être des mâles alpha,
mais ils commencent à jouer et à former des coalitions
derrière le dos des autres.
Ils deviennent extrêmement influents,
et on peut même avoir des mâles âgés
qui sont plus influents que l'alpha mâle lui-même.
Par exemple,
j'ai beaucoup travaillé avec ces trois mâles
dans un zoo néerlandais, il y a longtemps.
Celui qui se trouve au milieu est un mâle alpha de 17 ans.
Celui qu'il épouille, sur le côté, est deux fois plus âgé,
et lui a permis de devenir le leader.
Vous vous doutez donc que ce vieux mâle est très puissant,
puisque c'est lui qui a « fait » le mâle alpha.
Le mâle situé à droite est,
individuellement, le mâle le plus fort.
En faisant des tests en captivité,
on voit que ce mâle n'a aucun souci ni avec l'un ni avec l'autre,
Il a juste un souci avec la combinaison des deux.
En fait, ce phénomène social de coalition qui a lieu chez les chimpanzés
complexifie largement leur organisation.
Il peut permettre, notamment,
au plus petit parmi les mâles de devenir le mâle alpha.
Pas besoin d'être le plus grand et le plus fort.
Même le plus petit des mâles, s'il a de bons amis, et les rend heureux,
ou le soutien des femelles,
peut devenir le mâle alpha.
Ce système de coalitions complexifie donc les choses.
Ici, aux États-Unis, j'attends toujours
les primaires, la fin des primaires,
parce que c'est un moment où il faut faire preuve d'unité.
Je vais vous montrer comment l'unité se manifeste chez les chimpanzés.
Vous voyez ici deux mâles à gauche
debout, côte à côte.
Vous voyez bien leurs grandes canines.
Côte à côte, ils font une démonstration pour le reste du groupe :
« Nous sommes ensemble. Nous sommes unis. »
Les mâles sur la droite marchent ensemble, synchronisés:
c'est une autre manière de manifester l'unité.
Faire preuve d'unité est donc extrêmement important
dans un système de coalitions ;
et comme je disais, j'attends toujours de voir ça aux primaires
parce que vous avez alors deux membres du même parti
qui se sont battus l'un contre l'autre,
et qui doivent s'unir à un moment donné.
Ça donne lieu à des situations très embarrassantes.
Les rivaux doivent s'accepter mutuellement
et être solidaires,
ce qui est absolument essentiel pour l'unité du parti,
sinon, le parti pourrait s'effondrer.
Et, si ça ne fonctionne pas, comme dans ce cas particulier --
(Rires)
le parti se retrouve dans le pétrin
faute d'avoir fait preuve d'unité.
C'est donc une dimension essentielle du système de coalitions,
et c'est quelque chose que nous partageons avec les chimpanzés.
Comment devenir un mâle alpha ?
Tout d'abord, vous devez être impressionnant et intimidant,
faire preuve de vigueur par moments,
et montrer que vous êtes très fort.
Il y a toutes sortes de façons d'y parvenir.
Mais vous devez aussi vous montrer généreux.
Par exemple, lorsque les mâles partent en campagne
pour détrôner le leader,
ce qui peut prendre deux ou trois mois,
ils testent toutes les coalitions présentes au sein du groupe,
ils se montrent également très généreux.
Ils partagent aisément la nourriture entre eux
ou se mettent à chatouiller les bébés des femelles...
En temps normal, les mâles ne s'intéressent pas beaucoup aux bébés,
mais lorsqu'ils sont en campagne,
ils s'y intéressent beaucoup, ils les chatouillent,
et cherchent à se faire apprécier des femelles.
(Rires)
Ainsi, chez les humains,
je suis très intrigué par ces hommes qui sont candidats
qui soulèvent les bébés comme ceci.
Ça ne plait pas forcément aux bébés --
(Rires)
mais c'est un signal adressé au reste du monde :
ils doivent les tenir en l'air.
Et j'étais vraiment intrigué par
la candidate féminine de la dernière élection
qui tenait les bébés plutôt comme ceci,
ce qui plaît réellement aux bébés.
Mais elle, bien sûr, n'avait pas besoin de montrer
qu'elle pouvait tenir un bébé sans le faire tomber,
contrairement aux hommes.
C'est donc une stratégie très commune,
et les mâles chimpanzés passent beaucoup de temps
à chercher l'appréciation des uns et des autres,
lorsqu'ils sont en campagne.
Alors, quels sont les avantages et les inconvénients
d'être un mâle alpha ?
Le plus gros avantage, c'est les femelles.
La nourriture n'importe pas.
Les mâles chimpanzés peuvent passer une semaine sans manger
s'il y a une femelle en chaleur qui les intéresse sexuellement.
La nourriture est secondaire par rapport au sexe.
Et donc le mâle chimpanzé --
En tant que biologistes évolutionnistes, bien sûr, nous avons une explication :
le sexe mène à la reproduction,
et le succès reproductif est la clef de l'évolution.
C'est comme ça que tout évolue.
Donc si les mâles peuvent renforcer leur succès reproductif
en élevant leur rang,
alors ces mâles acquièrent automatiquement l'ambition d'élever leur rang.
Voilà pour les avantages.
Parmi les inconvénients, il y a le devoir
de garantir le bonheur de ses partenaires.
Donc si vous arrivez au pouvoir avec le support d'un vieux mâle,
vous devez laisser ce vieux mâle s'accoupler avec des femelles.
Si vous ne le faites pas, ce vieux mâle va se fâcher contre vous
et vous le perdrez en tant que partenaire.
Il y a donc une transaction qui s'opère.
Si vous devenez mâle alpha de cette façon, vos partenaires doivent être satisfaits.
C'est le premier inconvénient.
Le deuxième est le fait que tout le monde envie votre statut.
Le statut de mâle alpha est une place très importante,
et tout le monde veut vous la prendre.
Alors vous devez constamment vous méfier.
Vous devez être très vigilant.
Par exemple, vous devez rompre les coalitions des autres,
ce que les mâles chimpanzés font très souvent :
diviser pour mieux régner.
Et c'est une situation stressante, et en fait, on a des données sur ça.
Les données viennent du terrain,
des babouins et non des chimpanzés dans ce cas,
où ils ont fait des échantillons fécaux des babouins
et ont analysé leur teneur en gluco-corticoïdes.
Et ce que vous voyez ici est un graphique
où vous voyez que plus le babouin mâle a un classement inférieur,
plus son niveau de cortisol est élevé
dans les matières fécales.
Mais le mâle alpha, comme vous le voyez,
a un niveau aussi élevé que les mâles les plus inférieurs.
Alors on pourrait penser que d'être un mâle alpha est merveilleux,
mais c'est en fait une position très stressante
et on peut démontrer cela physiologiquement.
Maintenant, quelles sont les obligations ?
Et ici, pour moi, ça devient vraiment intéressant,
et ça change beaucoup de l'image typique du mâle alpha
Le mâle alpha a deux types d'obligations.
Une est de maintenir la paix dans le groupe.
C'est le rôle de contrôle,
contrôler les luttes dans le groupe.
Et le deuxième est d'être le plus empathique,
le chef consolateur, en gros, de la nation, si je peux dire.
Alors premièrement, maintenir la paix.
C'est un mâle qui arrête une bagarre entre deux femelles.
Deux femelles à gauche et à droite
se crient dessus pour de la nourriture,
car la nourriture est importante pour les femelles.
Alors il arrête la bagarre entre elles et se met entre elles comme ceci.
Et je trouve ça très intéressant, quand les mâles alpha font ça,
ils deviennent impartiaux.
Ils ne soutiennent ni leur mère ni leur meilleur ami -
non, non, ils arrêtent les bagarres,
et ils soutiennent l'opprimé en général.
Et ça les rend très populaires dans le groupe
parce qu'ils offrent de la sécurité
aux membres les plus bas du classement.
Alors ils deviennent impartiaux,
ce qui est un état inhabituel pour un chimpanzé
parce qu'ils sont normalement très attachés à leurs amis.
Les mâles alpha qui sont très bons à ça
peuvent être très efficaces pour maintenir la paix.
Et deuxièmement, ils montrent aussi de l'empathie envers les autres.
Maintenant, je fais beaucoup de recherche sur l'empathie,
et je ne pourrais pas tout expliquer
mais aujourd'hui on étudie l'empathie parmi les rongeurs et les chiens
chez les éléphants et les primates,
tout sorte d'animaux.
Ce que vous voyez ici sont deux bonobos.
Celle qui est devant
s'est fait tabasser.
Celle qui est à l’arrière met ses bras autour d'elle et la console.
En fait, nous mesurons l'empathie chez les enfants comme ceci aussi,
en regardant comment ils réagissent avec les individus en difficulté.
Et les hommes hauts placés, ils le font beaucoup.
Les mâles hauts placés offrent un énorme réconfort dans le groupe,
et ils vont là où il y a des tremblements de terre
ou des ouragans
et ils apportent du réconfort.
Le pape le fait. Les présidents le font.
C'est le travail de tous les leaders du monde
La reine le fait, etc.
Ils doivent tous le faire.
Alors apporter du réconfort - et c'est une tâche très importante.
Et les mâles qui font bien ces deux choses
maintenir la paix et offrir du réconfort,
ils deviennent des leaders très populaires
Et en fait, il y a de l'intérêt personnel impliqué
Ils ne le font pas juste pour le groupe
parce que ça stabilise aussi leur position.
Plus un mâle alpha devient populaire,
et plus les autres le respectent et l'admirent,
et plus sa position est défendue
au cas où elle est contestée par quelqu'un d'autre
parce que, alors, le groupe entier va soutenir ce mâle
car il veulent garder un leader qui est bon pour eux.
Le groupe soutient donc beaucoup les mâles qui sont de bons leaders
et il ne soutient pas du tout les tyrans.
Et quand un tyran perd sa position,
il peut finir dans une très mauvaise situation.
Voilà des données sur le comportement consolateur
chez les chimpanzés
et vous voyez pour les individus de moyen et bas classements
que les femelles le font plus que les mâles
En gros, ça, c'est la communauté entière.
On le voit dans chaque étude sur l'empathie des mammifères
que les femelles en ont plus que les mâles.
Mais regardez le mâle alpha.
Le mâle alpha fait beaucoup plus que le reste.
Voilà les données sur le mâle alpha en tant que chef consolateur, en gros.
Je vais finir avec quelque chose sur les femelles alpha.
Voilà une image de Mama, la femelle alpha dans le zoo d'Arnhem
où je travaillais avant,
qui est partout sur internet,
je crois 100 millions de clics à date
pour une vidéo d'elle en train de mourir à l'âge de 59 ans,
l'année dernière.
Mama était le centre absolu du groupe.
Elle n'était pas capable physiquement de dominer les mâles.
Elle était classée en dessous des mâles, mais était le centre de la communauté
et si la communauté était en difficulté,
tout le monde finissait dans les bras de Mama.
Donc elle était une figure très importante.
Donc je ne veux pas minimiser la position des femelles alpha
pour les chimpanzés.
Et après nous avons une espèce qui est aussi proche de nous
que le chimpanzé : le bonobo.
On oublie souvent le bonobo, mais ils ont une société matriarcale
et l'individu alpha est généralement une femelle.
En général, c'est une femelle au sommet de la communauté
et on sait peu sur la façon dont ça advient,
comment elles accèdent à la position et ce qu'elles en font
car nous savons beaucoup moins sur les bonobos en général.
Mais je veux souligner
que l'alpha dans le groupe n'est pas forcément un mâle,
et qu'en fait, chez un de nos parents proches, c'est une femelle.
Le message avec lequel je veux vous laisser
est que si vous regardez les hommes dans notre société
qui sont le chef de, disons,
une famille, une entreprise, Washington ou autre,
vous les appelez mâle alpha,
vous ne devriez pas insulter les chimpanzés
en utilisant le mauvais terme.
(Rires)
On ne doit pas appeler un tyran un mâle alpha.
Quelqu'un qui est grand, fort, qui intimide et insulte tout le monde
n'est pas forcément un mâle alpha.
Un mâle alpha a toutes sortes de qualités,
et j'ai vu des mâles alpha tyranniques chez les chimpanzés,
ça arrive,
mais la plupart de ceux qu'on a
ont des qualités de leader
et sont intégrés dans leur communauté
et, comme Amos vers la fin,
ils sont aimés et respectés.
Alors c'est très différent de ce que l'on pourrait penser.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)